In 6.004, we have a specific
plan on how we’ll use registers
in our designs, which we call
the single-clock synchronous
discipline.
Looking at the sketch of
a circuit on the left,
we see that it
consists of registers
— the rectangular icons with
the edge-triggered symbol —
and combinational
logic circuits,
shown here as little clouds
with inputs and outputs.
Remembering that there is no
combinational path between
a register’s input and output,
the overall circuit has no
combinational cycles.
In other words, paths from
system inputs and register
outputs to the
inputs of registers
never visit the same
combinational block twice.
A single periodic
clock signal is shared
among all the clocked devices.
Using multiple clock
signals is possible,
but analyzing the
timing for signals
that cross between clock
domains is quite tricky,
so life is much simpler when all
registers use the same clock.
The details of
which data signals
change when are
largely unimportant.
All that matters is that signals
hooked to register inputs are
stable and valid for long enough
to meet the registers’ setup
time.
And, of course, stay stable long
enough to meet the registers’
hold time.
We can guarantee that the
dynamic discipline is obeyed
by choosing the clock
period to be greater
then the t_PD of every
path from register outputs
to register inputs,
plus, of course, the
registers’ setup time.
A happy consequence of choosing
the clock period in this way
is that at the moment of
the rising clock edge,
there are no other
noise-inducing logic
transitions happening
anywhere in the circuit.
Which means there
should be no noise
problems when we update the
stored state of each register.
Our next task is to
learn how to analyze
the timing of a single-clock
synchronous system.
Here’s a model of a particular
path in our synchronous system.
A large digital system
will have many such paths
and we have to do the analysis
below for each one in order
to find the path that will
determine the smallest
workable clock period.
As you might suspect, there are
computed-aided design programs
that will do these
calculations for us.
There’s an upstream register,
whose output is connected
to a combinational logic circuit
which generates the input
signal, labeled STAR, to
the downstream register.
Let’s build a carefully-drawn
timing diagram showing when
each signal in the system
changes and when it is stable.
The rising edge of the clock
triggers the upstream register,
whose output (labeled
Q_R1) changes
as specified by the
contamination and propagation
delays of the register.
Q_R1 maintains its old value
for at least the contamination
delay of REG1, and then
reaches its final stable value
by the propagation
delay of REG1.
At this point Q_R1
will remain stable
until the next
rising clock edge.
Now let’s figure out the
waveforms for the output
of the combinational
logic circuit,
marked with a red
star in the diagram.
The contamination
delay of the logic
determines the earliest time
STAR will go invalid measured
from when Q_R1 went invalid.
The propagation
delay of the logic
determines the
latest time STAR will
be stable measured from
when Q_R1 became stable.
Now that we know
the timing for STAR,
we can determine whether
STAR will meet the setup
and hold times for the
downstream register REG2.
Time t1 measures how
long STAR will stay valid
after the rising clock edge.
t1 is the sum of REG1’s
contamination delay
and the logic’s
contamination delay.
The HOLD time for
REG2 measures how long
STAR has to stay valid after
the rising clock edge in order
to ensure correct operation.
So t1 has to be greater than
or equal to the HOLD time
for REG2.
Time t2 is the sum
of the propagation
delays for REG1 and the logic,
plus the SETUP time for REG2.
This tells us the earliest time
at which the next rising clock
edge can happen and still ensure
that the SETUP time for REG2
is met.
So t2 has to be less
than or equal to the time
between rising clock edges,
called the clock period
or tCLK.
If the next rising
clock happens before t2,
we’ll be violating the
dynamic discipline for REG2.
So we have two
inequalities that must
be satisfied for every
register-to-register path
in our digital system.
If either inequality
is violated,
we won’t be obeying the
dynamic discipline for REG2
and our circuit will not be
guaranteed to work correctly.
Looking at the inequality
involving tCLK,
we see that the propagation
delay of the upstream register
and setup time for the
downstream register
take away from the time
available useful work performed
by the combinational logic.
Not surprisingly, designers
try to use registers
that minimize these two times.
What happens if there’s no
combinational logic between
the upstream and
downstream registers?
This happens when designing
shift registers, digital delay
00:05:master latch.
So the following
two specifications
are determined by the
timing of the master latch.
t_SETUP is the amount
of time that the D input
must be valid and stable
before the rising clock
edge and t_HOLD is
the amount of time
that D must be valid and
stable after the rising clock.
This region of stability
surrounding the clock edge
ensures that we’re obeying
the dynamic discipline
for the master latch.
So when you use a D register
component from a manufacturer’s
gate library,
you’ll need to look up these
four timing specifications
in the register’s data sheet
in order to analyze the timing
of your overall circuit.
We’ll see how this analysis
is done in the next section. hold times of the
downstream register,
assuming we can’t predict
the sign of the skew.
The clock period, tCLK,
characterizes the performance
of our system.
You may have noticed that
Intel is willing to sell you
processor chips that run at
different clock frequencies,
e.g., a 1.7 GHz processor
vs. a 2 GHz processor.
Did you ever wonder how
those chips are different?
As is turns out they’re not!
What’s going on is that
variations in the manufacturing
process mean that some chips
have better tPDs than others.
On fast chips, a smaller
tPD for the logic
means that they can have a
smaller tCLK and hence a higher
clock frequency.
So Intel manufactures many
copies of the same chip,
measures their tPDs and
selects the fast ones to sell
as higher-performance parts.
That’s what it takes to
make money in the chip biz!